[Music]
[Applause]
Chase Daniel look who's becoming an
analyst I love this Chase Daniel I'll
give you the backstory uh I think it's
14 years in the NFL and a two-time
Heisman Trophy candidate at Missouri and
he hosts the Chase Daniel show you'll
find that on
YouTube how's it been what's the
reaction so far it's it's been good you
know I'm still trying to find my way a
little bit but um you know appearing on
NFL Total Access on Fridays and I
decided hey like we also have a podcast
with Trey Wingo called chasing it we
just had Travis Kel on the episode blew
up so we just continue to keep getting
guests and just trying to find my way
but this this Chase Daniel show on
YouTube it's interesting because it's
just a quarterback breakdown and I I try
to pick a few guys every week maybe four
or five guys and really go in from an
aspect of like what I was for for 14
years I was just in the room and it was
like day after game film The Good the
Bad the Ugly I don't care like I'm just
going to say how it is like I'm I'm just
going to break it down and I'm actually
able to Tate it on the screen so I'm
able to Circle things draw up route
contexts explain to the average viewer
what goes through quarterback's heads
and where maybe he should have thrown
the ball a quarterback take for instance
CJ stra just broke him down like the
dude is playing unbelievable but like he
missed some throws all right so I'm I'm
going to be able to tell you that and
it's just it's just a way like football
is very very complicated and complex so
I try to break it down to the average
viewer level and say hey here's what
happened here's what he should have done
or he did this well and uh it's taken
off I've been pretty surprised at at uh
at everything that's been going on with
it right now well you did the video
where you called out the Cowboys defense
after what Brock pie did so give us give
the audience an idea of what exactly did
Brock py do and what role did the uh
Cowboys defense play yeah that that that
was my highest grossing video it like
150,000 views in like 24 hours so
there's some San Francisco 49ers
faithful fans that want to see it no no
no that's Cowboy fans that want to see
it too they want to know what's wrong
with their their team I would break down
the Cowboys every week if I were you
chase yeah I you know I and and it's
interesting because I just posted a Dak
video we can get to that later but but
the way Brock was able to play on Sunday
night I mean you know the thing with
Brock it's either him or the system
that's all I've heard it's him or the
system it's him or the system and why
can't it be both right it's a perfect
co-mingling of of two people K shanan
Brock pie and going at it because he's
had other quarterbacks before right that
haven't been able to run the system as
efficient as Brock and it's not like
he's just checking it down he's going
through progressions the game plan was
excellent you know we always talk on
offense especially what they're doing in
San Francisco we talk about blitzing the
defense what does that mean shifts
motions checks different Personnel
groups everything like that Brock is
handling it so like calm and that's the
biggest thing I've seen from him is so
what you're saying is the ners are the
aggressor that they're actually blitzing
the defense there and Brock and Brock is
aggressive he's not like Jimmy G he's
aggressive downfield yeah I I was
actually surprised at how how much
they're taking shots downfield it's not
these old like screen of course they
have it like but you know you're only as
good as the 10 other players around you
and I'm telling you right now this San
Francisco 49ers offense is the best in
the league and it's not even close the
way they're able to handle different
times within the game different looks
that Dallas's defense was giving them
and just the play calling genius
obviously everyone knows about Kyle
Shanahan but you got CMC and and
honestly when I've broke down Brock a
couple times on my on my show I've been
really impressed with Brandon auk like
the dude has taken his game to a
completely different level everyone
knows about KD everyone knows about CMC
Debo okay but Brandon auk I'm telling
you right now like he's a he looks to me
like a thinner faster Mike Williams even
and and I keep breaking him down I'm
just like man like the way he's running
like he looks 44 speed 43 speed he's got
fresh legs it's it's really impressive
and honestly like all those weapons at
the end of the day you're going to end
up helding Brock is it fair to start
looking at Shawn P
the way we do Bill bellich and that is
bich without Tom Brady and Shawn pyton
without Drew Brees what kind of coaches
are they yeah I don't know I I I just
think he inherited a a pretty tough
situation there like I'm I'm a big Shawn
pton fan but at the end of the day like
you gotta win right and the offense just
looks so like stuck in a rut and and I
don't know if it's Russell because
honestly like Russell has played well
like four like three or four games out
of the year and it's really been their
defense which no one was expecting you
can't tell me that CU I played in that
division um for like five or six years
especially the last two years their
defense especially their pass defense
has been unbelievable and they played
really well last night you hold the
Chiefs to one touchdown and you end up
losing the game they they they came back
late late in the late in the game but
you look at Johan pyton and what he's
done I mean I think eventually like he's
G to end up being like hey like all
right wholesale fire cell changes who
knows what's going to happen but I just
think that he eventually will get his
guys in there and whether it's Russell
Wilson in there I don't know I can't
tell you know I'm not in the building
but I know a lot of those guys that are
and I just think they're trying to
really find their way as an offense and
and and the defense isn't really helping
them out very much but is Russ the type
of quarterback Shawn pyton wants well I
mean everyone's talking about it right
everyone's talking about hey is is is
you know Shawn pyton he needs a dropback
style quarterback look Russ in in my
opinion is his best out of the pocket
right so Russ you have to have a really
smart quarterback for that offense
because with Shawn Payton's offense I
mean I was in it for seven years and it
is very difficult Russ Russ is Russ is
really smart he's cereal type
quarterback can he make plays within the
pocket on time and in Rhythm it's not
really Russ's game he's done it this
year and you look at the big splash
plays it's been on the outside of the
pocket when plays break down making
plays with his
legs talking to Chase Daniel and you
could check out his uh YouTube channel
his show uh the Chase Daniel show on
YouTube you mentioned you broke down Dak
Prescot what did you see good and bad
yeah um I broke it down put it up last
night and it was a little slow and I
just I just looked and it's Dallas fans
are flocking to it because um I was just
I was just honest I mean I labeled it is
Dak the problem and for my for my
opinion just watching the game it's not
Dak like like you watch the San
Francisco 49ers game I think that's just
an anomaly in my opinion because the the
49ers defense all they did and now now
teams might try to like replace it and
do the same thing they were just playing
man-to-man coverage man it was like come
up press Dallas Cowboys get home with
all their receivers get home with four
rushers and and Bosa and all those guys
on the off and Dak had no time to throw
the ball his three picks came late in
the game I think he only played 39 plays
in that game because they were getting
blown out and they ended up putting
Cooper rush in so for the most part I
think Dak has done a really good job
this season it wasn't great tape
honestly uh when I watched the 49ers
team and I don't know if that's a Mike
McCarthy problem and he's getting used
to still calling plays and trying to
figure out the offense or if it's if
it's Dak but I I just at the end of the
day when you look at it from from that
game it's just like to me I think it's
going to be an anomaly yeah but it feels
like we're waiting for Dak Prescott to
be somebody he's not yeah right I mean
he he's not going to be that upper
echelon quarterback at least it it
doesn't appear after eight years years
are you really going to change seven
years yeah yeah I mean look look he's
it's it's a hard question because you
look at this league is such a game to
game type league right like what have
you done for me lately you look at the
past three or four years Dax had had
really good years but they've never want
being able to w win the big game
especially against San Francisco last
year knocked him out of the playoffs and
So eventually like you know Jerry Jones
and Mike McCarthy if he's going to be
the guy moving forward they got to see
something that says hey Dak you're in
the top eight top five quarterbacks and
not only are you a game manager you
better win games with your arm when we
need you to win games and eventually
it's got to come down to that and you
got to have the players around you which
they do they've always had the players
that's never been the question with the
Dallas Cowboys the talent has always
been there you know it it's like hey can
you put it together for a string of
games can you get on some streaks can
you win big games in the playoffs and
that is not what the Dallas Cowboys have
been the Bears know what they have in
Justin fields right you know what kind
of quarterback he is has he shown you
enough have you broken down his tape
that you would say if I have the number
one or number two overall pick I'm G to
still stay with Justin Fields well you
got Caleb Williams and Drake May right
like that those are the two that are
probably Justin Fields a franchise
quarterback I mean the way he's play so
so I I break it I I watched every single
one of their games because I'm so
interested in like just what was going
wrong you take the first three games of
the year and it was a crapshoot on
offense like they couldn't do any it
looked to me like Luke gy was calling
plays like he had a statue back there at
quarterback I'm G to be completely
honest with you and the Innovation
wasn't there they were barely moving uh
like pre- Snap motions or shift just
easy stuff so they were just in stagnant
formations he was under Center a lot
like I watched the the Chiefs game and I
was thinking what in the what like you
have this guy this guy is not an under
Center dropback play action passer He's
Just Not That guy that's just not who he
is and he did and then you go back and
you look at the Broncos game and the
commander game and it's like a com he's
thrown eight touchdowns in those games a
completely different quarterback a
completely different offense it's like
why did you wait so long because you
look back last year that's exactly what
their offense was like yeah until the
New England game and the New England
game that Luke said H handcuffs are off
just run man just go and then he started
his tear through the league and then he
started again like that this year and
then the last two games right he's been
he's been unbelievable in the offense
the offense has changed and that's
what's really good like you have to put
this guy if you want him to be your
franchise quarterback which I'm still on
the fence about I'm not sure if he can
the last two games sure sure is like it
but he needs to be in an offense like
Luke gy was running he needs to be in a
Lamar Jackson type offense where hey
it's RPO it's quick game it's screens
it's it's quarterback run it's
decision-making I think that's something
that he continues to get better on I've
seen a really big difference in him from
the first three weeks to the last two
weeks is his his processing speed has
gone through the roof it's not like
where he's holding it he's looking at
one and just taking a sack because he
had the most sacks over the last two
years when he's holding the ball four
plus seconds now I can't even see it
it's like onew run one-w run so whatever
he did or whatever change they made on
offense it's working yeah I they were
trying to make him into something that
he's not also you know throw on first
down like don't don't make it so it's
predictable on third down and you're
right he was back there as if he was you
know Payton Manning and he's not going
to carve you up I would treat him just
like Carolina did Cam Newton go out and
be Cam Newton don't try to be anything
other than who you are and that's who
Justin Fields is he's he's GNA be that
guy he's not going to be consistent he's
gonna have big play you know
capabilities
but man they got a big decision here at
the end of the year and I don't know if
he could play his way back into Chicago
yeah I mean look it's it's an
interesting decision because it is
decision time coming up and if but if he
continues playing this way and they can
actually put I mean let let's be real
other than DJ Moore they they don't have
many Playmakers on offense like you got
to surround yourself with guys and I
love the Cam Newton analogy because it's
me like everyone like it went viral
everyone was like oh my gosh he just
called out the coaching right like when
Justin Fields called out the coaching
but to me I took it way different than
anyone else it was him finally saying
look like the coaching is fine okay but
maybe it was there's a fine line
especially in quarterback rooms of over
coaching right and that's what I think
was happening to Justin finally just
said hey go out be yourself be yourself
show your personality do what you do and
he's starting to flourish in it they're
not holding them back he's just starting
to roll and so we'll see we'll see I
mean you know the next 10 12 games the
only way that he in Chicago is to win
his way because if if they win then they
don't get Caleb Williams or Drake May
unless they trade for it so he can he
can prevent the Bears from getting that
next quarterback uh Chase it's great to
talk to you love to have you back on
promote your YouTube channel the Chase
Daniel show and uh congrats on the
success thanks guys thanks for having me
on Chase Daniel